why hello there Internet did you guys
get a haircut something looks a little
bit different about you guys are looking
fantastic
Thank You crusty if I would have a
porcupine what color would I want the
porcupine to be well I'm pretty sure
I've spent a lot of time on YouTube
looking at porcupine videos believe it
or not so I'm pretty confident when I
say I would like my porcupine to be the
normal porcupine color where did the I
come from and I just do well basically
around 2002 when the first iPod came out
yeah that iPod I decided to start going
but I just seen on the Internet and here
we are several years later I'm still
agitated very depressing I was YouTube
changed my life well basically pretty
much 99% of the people that I currently
know I have met because of the internet
or YouTube so I would have a lot less
friends if it weren't for YouTube
speaking of which I asked you as a
question have you ever met anyone online
and then met them in real life
and they turned out to be not quite the
person that you were talking to online
well there's a word for that it's called
catfish and here's the actual definition
of a catfish it's like I said somebody
pretends to be someone or not even a
local or other social media outlets you
create false ideas particularly to
pursue a deceptive online romance so now
I'm gonna play a fun little game with
you guys gonna be called one lie two
truths or if you so prefer two truths 1
lie I tell you three stories of
situations of people that I've met
online and you got to tell me which one
is not true so sadly I've never actually
had any crazy online romance stories so
I'm just gonna tell you some normal
stories of people that I met online
unless you count annoying orange and
passion fruits I kind of think they have
a little thing going on are you ready I
happen to be taking a trip to Vegas
someone who I never knew tweeted me and
said hey I'm in Vegas do you want to
take a tour of our office I said sure
they said ok I'll pick you up at your
hotel I said ok this is my hotel then
this said person comes to my hotel picks
me up and I go for a tour of their
office and
still alive so obviously that one must
be pretty true I met a guy in a band on
MySpace their band happened to be
touring through Pittsburgh they needed a
place to stay so I said hey you guys can
come stay with me and I'm still alive so
maybe that one that's true
I've always wanted to be an astronaut so
I joined this astronaut forum group I
posted a lot of pictures and videos
talking about how much I wanted to be an
astronaut then I met an astronaut then I
met the astronaut in real life he turns
out they weren't actually an astronaut
is still the highest oh maybe that one
is true so to figure out which one of my
stories is false click this annotation
right here and just a side note some
even random people off the net could be
potentially dangerous so please be
careful if you do choose to meet someone
from the internet actually should
probably just be careful with general in
life because people can be creepy that
was supposed to be a creepy face did I
fail yeah I failed I failed when I do
that it's stupid you have a sign
I'm studying school tomorrow okay go on
and I know what to do a people can laugh
at me
oh why would they laugh at you are
people gonna stare at me well I mean
probably they're probably gonna look at
you because you gonna be sitting up to
the McClouds the rubbings a I cook in a
heat
daddy go why are you crying
there's a video here I am feeling so bad
for her because she's crying and she's
upset because she's starting school and
she actually wasn't crying sweetie
Christine this was kind of an awkward
request okay
look like I'm making it with my iPhone
right now you know I never did figure
out why my sister was sewing tapestry at
1:00 a.m. on a Saturday night maybe you
guys should ask her go to Jenna's page
and ask her why she was sewing tapestry
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of ask IJ as I was talking about
earlier in my little 2 truths 1 lie I
want to figure out what my lie is just
check out this annotation voila or right
there
and it will let you know what my lie was
until then I will see you guys next time
and probably the next video I post will
be a vlog university videos so stay
tuned for that thank you guys for
watching I'll see you soon
I was gonna say something else there but
then I didn't say something else
so no stop the video